I'd like to welcome you back and hope that you all had,
um,
really good brakes.
We'll be talking this week about malaria,
uh,
both today and on Wednesday.
And I think I may be saying a couple of things that you may find surprising.
I suppose to,
this may be an assumption that when I mentioned malaria,
that most of you think of it as an exotic tropical disease and probably think
that it's very distant from us and has relatively little to do with the modern
world or with modern history and probably nothing at all to do with the United
States and with those of us here.
But the point I wanting to make this time and next is that the reality of
malaria is quite different from not that when we've come to talk about this
disease,
I could say that of all human diseases,
it's one of the oldest and some question,
a question that some of you might ask me is of all the diseases in our course,
which is the one that in the aggregate has caused the most human suffering and
death.
And I think that of all of the diseases in our course,
it's probably malaria,
which has,
uh,
has not primacy the relationship if human beings to malaria has been so enclose
and so extensive that we could also say that we as a species and malaria as a
disease have evolved together and that the human genome bears the imprint of our
experience with malaria.
Good examples of that are a couple of genetic diseases that I'd like to mention
or one that may be familiar to you.
Also,
one being sickle cell anemia,
um,
a second being thalassemia and the third being what's called Duffy negativity.
Now all of these are genetic diseases and they have in common the feature that,
um,
there's a difference between the trait,
which it's a recessive in all three cases.
They're recessive features.
And so a Hetero Zygote that is a person who has just one,
um,
uh,
the w x chromosome rather than accent.
Why?
Uh,
expressing the trait for the disease enjoys a protection from,
but if in fact you have,
are a homozygote and have it done both x and y chromosomes,
and you develop this syndrome for sickle cell anemia,
uh,
instead you have a terrible disease that leads to,
it causes sickle cell.
It affects the quality of the hemoglobin and the red cells,
and therefore it leads to anemia,
occlusion of blood vessels,
sometimes hypoxia and serious respiratory diseases.
So it's a fatal illness in many cases.
But if you have the trait,
then in a highly malarial area,
you have a great selective advantage in enjoying a great deal of resistance to
immunity.
And so in terms of heavy human evolution and intensely malarial areas,
there was a strong Darwinian,
uh,
pressure for the retention of the sickle cell trait.
The same would be true of Thalassemia,
which affects not the quality of the red cells,
but rather their quantity and leads to,
again,
a terrible complications in,
uh,
in homozygotes and,
with asthma.
Um,
and,
uh,
terrible anemia or Duffy negativity,
which is another genetic disease that leads again to terrible diseases.
Another feature of malaria,
apart from the fact that our genome has actually been strongly influenced by our
history with malaria is that until very recently,
it extended more or less across the globe affecting not only the tropics in
Africa,
Asia and South America,
but also the north,
including most of Europe and North America.
So I thought I'd show you a map of malaria in the United States in the 19th
century.
Uh,
just to give you an idea,
this is 1882 to show you how extensively prevalent it was in this country as
recently as the late 19th century.
And indeed it comes up.
Oliver Wendell Holmes wrote a book on malaria in New England.
This is a map of 1912 when it's receded a great deal and is primarily a disease
of the south.
But remember that it had a major impact on public health in this country until
the end of the Second World War,
which is when it was eradicated in the United States.
It's sobering to remember,
for example,
that the Centers for disease control,
the CDC in Atlanta was originally founded as an anti malarial agency.
And that the disease played a major role and the settlement of the West and in
the economic and social development of the south.
And if you read Mark Twain for example,
you can read a great deal about shivering along the banks of the Mississippi
River in terms of our discussion of relationship of diseases to the big picture
of history.
Malaria is also one of the diseases that I think helps us to make the case must
effectively malaria.
It's now believed,
played a major part in the fall,
for example,
of the Roman Empire when an epidemic of Falciparum Malaria,
um,
led to the disruption of agriculture and the Roman legions.
And I'm not trying to say that malaria caused the downfall of the Roman empire.
I'm saying that it was a major factor leading to the kinds of military problems
and social dislocation that we can't ignore.
And discussing that major series of events,
it's led to major impacts on the outcome and on the conduct of warfare one need
go back only to the Second World War when malaria was a PR major preoccupation
of the armies on both sides of the conflict.
It had an enormous role and impact on European expansion and colonization.
And one of the great challenges to colonial expansion in the Indian subcontinent
and in Africa was what to do about the problem of malaria.
It's affected the pattern of human habitation and settlement,
the way that cities and towns are built across the landscape where human
habitation often was a form of prophylaxis from malaria and people live far from
swampy areas and often on high ground above dangerous wetlands.
Low down malaria is also a major factor in economic development and under
development today in ways that we'll be discussing a decisive factor in its
prevalence and in its history has always been the relationship of human beings
to agriculture and the environment.
That is to say that intensive forms of agriculture with a modern livestock
raising practices,
modern crop rotations,
what are management,
ecological sanitation with improved housing and conditions of diet,
wages and clothing have led wherever they've been introduced to a spontaneous
recession of malaria and much better health outcomes.
And this has been a major factor in the divergence between the global north and
the global south.
The north with modernized intensive systems of agriculture and in the south and
said the persistence of extensive forms of practice that are conducive for
reasons we'll be examining to the transmission of malaria.
So malaria both reflects and reinforces developmental differences and
disparities.
Now,
let's remember that malaria is vitally important in our world today.
Let me give you an example of some of the,
uh,
the pictures that represent the global burden of malaria.
And let me show you a map of where malaria is prevalent today.
That is in the 21st century.
Indeed at the moment,
one can say the statistics are extraordinary.
About 500,000 people becomes seriously ill of malaria every year,
approximately a million people die of it.
The majority of them being children under five and pregnant women concentrated
particularly in sub Saharan Africa.
In fact,
one can say that a child dies of malaria in Africa today,
every 30 seconds,
making this disease of global public health emergency along with HIV,
AIDS and tuberculosis.
Let's look at more particularly the areas.
This is the epicenter,
if you like,
of the,
uh,
present day resurgence of malaria as a major,
major public health problem.
Uh,
and there are malaria kills 3000 children every day of the year.
The burden of malaria though,
is greater than statistics for mortality and morbidity suggest it is.
For example,
one of the worst possible complications of pregnancy.
It leads to high rates of miscarriage to maternal death through hemorrhaging and
severe anemia and all of the sequella that follow from severe low birth rate.
Malaria also can be transmitted vertically that is transplacentally from mother
to fetus and can lead to the birth of infants who are congenitally infected.
We also need to remember that it will say in a moment that malaria is a major
immunosuppressive disease and its victims therefore,
are highly susceptible to other opportunistic infections,
especially respiratory infections,
tuberculosis,
influenza,
pneumonia.
In those areas of the tropical world where malaria is hyper endemic and
transmission continues throughout the year,
the population at risk can be infected,
reinfected and super infected every single year.
If the victims of malaria survive,
they possess a painfully acquired immunity,
but it comes at a terrible price because repeated bouts of malaria lead to
severe neurological deficits and cognitive impairment.
The results are ineradicable,
poverty,
illiteracy and compromised economic growth,
a stunted development of civil society and political instability.
We'll be talking in a moment about Ronald Ross,
who was the Nobel laureate who was one of two people who discovered the mosquito
theory of transmission for disease.
And he wrote quite movingly that those malaria doesn't,
in areas where malaria is prevalent,
those it doesn't kill it.
Enslaves malaria.
In other words,
in our present world as a major contributor to inequalities between north and
south and to the economic and political international dependency of Third World
countries and the tropical world.
Well,
let's talk about the malaria also will be of interest to us because it's an
extremely complex disease.
And so we need to spend a little bit of time talking about how it's transmitted
and about its effects on the human body in order after that to talk about how,
uh,
the discoveries that led to,
it's our understanding of it.
And to the impact on society and on history.
Well,
until the end of the 19th century,
malaria was thought to be explained by a theory that you already know by Miasma
tourism.
In other words,
malaria was a form of bad air.
In fact,
that's what the word means from the Italian mollay bad and audio air.
So malaria was bad air that somehow a susceptible person inhaled and it caught
in his or her body or it was absorbed perhaps through the pores of the skin and
led in susceptible people to this terrible fever.
It was also sometimes called Paulo [inaudible] from uh,
the word for swamp.
So it was swamp fever.
So the disease then was absorbed or breathed in in some way.
In fact,
malaria isn't one disease,
it's a family of four different diseases caused by a parasite with an extremely
complex life cycle.
The parasite is known as the plasmodium and there are four species of plasmodium
that cause human malaria.
And I have them on your handout there,
plasmodium falciparum,
plasmodium vivax,
plasmodium Velodea,
and plasmodium of all.
Then for the purposes here,
the first to plasmodium falciparum,
plasmodium vivax are the most important medically and historically
and the ones we'll be talking about mostly now,
the plasmodium differ fundamentally from the other microbial pathogens we've
examined so far in the course bacteria for example,
and viruses and that they're much more complex lifeforms with complex life
cycles that we need to unravel.
Plasmodium were discovered in 1884 by our phones.
Love it all.
MMM.
There he is.
A French army doctor working in Algeria.
It turns out that the plasmodium don't exist free in the environment at any
stage of their lives.
Instead they're adopted to live either in the body of human beings or in the gut
of certain species of mosquitoes.
And
there we are.
Um,
this is an,
an awfully Miskito um,
having doing its thing that is to say,
uh,
having a blood meal,
which is the way that malaria is transmitted from person to person.
The plasmodium this again,
in a more schematic way,
um,
it gets the point across about the relationship of human beings and the mosquito
plus Modia migrate in the body of the insect.
To the salivary glands in the biting apparatus.
So abiding mosquito like this one is an effect and extremely efficient vector.
It's sometimes referred to as a flying syringe because what it does the mosquito
does is to inoculate the plasma Modia directly into the bloodstream of the host.
At this stage,
the parasite will move to look at what happens next.
The first thing we have is the mosquito,
uh,
taking a blood meal
and inoculating the plows Modia directly into the bloodstream of the unfortunate
victim.
At that stage in here,
we'll see one of the points about the plasma Modia is that it undergoes a series
of morphological changes and becoming distinct stages in the life in its life,
both in the human body and in the body of the insect.
Initially when it's injected,
it's known as a sport zone,
right?
And what it does next is it migrates after just a few hours after inoculation.
Say you were bitten,
uh,
right now,
within a few hours,
uh,
the plebs Modia in your bloodstream would have migrated to your liver.
And this begins the incubation period in which the plasmodium reproduces.
That is a sexually in the liver and uh,
you'll see it's reproduction.
And then after a number of,
uh,
just a number of days or weeks,
it's released again now in a new phase,
this time known as a marazonal right into the bloodstream.
So returns at that point to the bloodstream.
One of the points of the migration to the liver is not when it's in the liver,
it's safely beyond the detection of the human immune system.
And so it reproduces safely in the liver and then emerges on much more numerous
into the bloodstream and a new phase in its life cycle.
So at this point in the bloodstream,
what happens is that the mirror is white,
such what they're now called the new name of the parasite for that phase.
It enters into,
it attaches itself to and enters into red blood cells or erythrocytes.
Okay?
Once safely in side,
the red blood cell,
again,
it's not detected by the immune system,
it reproduces asexually
and you can see it doing so until at a certain point it has destroyed the red
blood cell and ruptures the red blood cell and the parasites return.
Once again to the bloodstream.
I have,
uh,
this is a picture,
these are of,
uh,
the,
by electron microscope of the actual rupturing of red blood cells and the
emergence once again of the parasites that have just reproduced,
uh,
returning to the open bloodstream at that point.
Um,
the much more numerous mirrors,
the lights keep repeating this process of invading red cells,
reproducing,
destroying the red blood cells,
and then bursting them at periodic intervals.
The interval of time that it takes is determined by the species of plasmodium
for Plasmodium Falciparum and Vyvanse acts,
it's every 48 hours.
And so,
um,
for plasmodium Malariae,
it's every 72 hours.
Now,
eventually among the brood of mirrors,
no whites that is,
let's see again,
um,
after it's gone through a number of cycles they produce among their offspring.
Okay,
what are called to new,
morphologically different stage in the lifecycle.
And that is gametocytes that are male and female and these are in the open
bloodstream.
And then the next,
an awful lean mosquito that takes a blood meal as it does.
So it sucks up the male and female gametocytes that reproduce sexually.
This time we see them here in the God and the body of the female mosquito.
And then that begins the phase of life in the body of the mosquito,
where once again we find it reproduces and eventually it leads to the production
of sporozoites that migrate once again to the biting apparatus,
the salivary glands of the mosquito,
the mosquito again,
texts and ineffective by,
and then it's next blood meal and the whole cycle.
This complex cycle of both asexual reproduction in the body of men and sexual
reproduction in the body of the mosquito,
the cycle is then complete.
No,
let's return for a second to,
uh,
the plasmodium and to the insect.
And,
uh,
let me just deal with the fact that in order,
the reason that the female,
and it's only female unlawful liens that,
um,
take blood meals on human beings.
And the reason that the female,
an awful lean does that is that it needs blood in order to mature it's eggs and
to lay them having taken a blood meal,
it's then able to,
she's able to mature her eggs and at that point,
um,
lays them and water.
And they pass through the cycle of Larva poop pay.
And then the adult Oskido known as an amalgam,
know what happens at that point.
It takes about a week for the eggs to develop as large a pool pie and then adult
mosquitoes.
And then the mosquito is ready to take flight and to visit you and me.
Now from the breeding site to the blood meal,
the anomalies,
mosquitoes have delicate wings under normally week flyers.
So normally she flies about no more than three kilometers or so from her
birthplace.
Most species of an awful Lee's avoid sunlight that dries up their wings and they
avoid strong winds.
But as they take,
they're able to orient themselves to places of human settlement.
Why?
Because on their antenna there are sensors that are highly stimulated by a
carbon dioxide in the air.
And so,
um,
this,
the carbon dioxide plume arising from human settlements and human bodies enables
the mosquitoes to be attracted to them having arrived at closer range.
The mosquitoes then detect with other sensors,
odors emanating from sweat.
They're also attracted by light and then it close range.
They finally use their vision to settle on the site of the body most suitable
for their feast and human beings cooperate in this enterprise and not an awfully
lean mosquitoes feast between dusk and dawn and they thereby attack sleeping
bodies,
lying mostly motionless.
Now when you hear the buzz of the harmless culex mosquito that buzzes noisily
around you and attracts your attention,
you can be happy because most an awful liens that transmit malaria are silent
and therefore don't disturb their hosts.
Now you're probably wondering
how is it that transmissions maintained if a fee,
most the vast majority of mosquitoes don't transmit malaria,
only the females of certain species of an often liens,
and I've included two on your handout as being most important to us.
Anopheles Gambiae,
which would be my candidate for the most deadly insect for human beings on our
planet and a [inaudible] which had was one of the most important vectors of
malaria in Europe and in parts of Africa.
Or you're probably wondering if a female anopheles mosquito lives on average
just a few weeks and needs to be infected herself before transmitting the
disease.
How can transmission be maintained?
There's a couple of facts that we need to remember.
First is the vast numbers of mosquitoes involved in areas where malaria is
endemic in most areas of high end emissivity no more than 2% or so of female
mosquitoes are infected at any given time,
but on average,
a human being can be thousands of times in a year.
And it's also true that an insect like an awful Lee's gone ba is famished and
doesn't feed a single time.
But having entered a place of human settlement feasts repeatedly moving from one
body to another,
thereby ensuring that crowded conditions in crowded conditions,
one malarial patient is a major source of danger to all of those around him or
her.
Well,
that's the story from the standpoint of the mosquito.
What happens to the human victim?
What are the symptoms of malaria?
How does the disease have its impact on the human body?
Well,
after the incubation period,
symptoms begin when the plasmodium have achieved a critical threshold number in
the bloodstream,
and it's then that the classical symptoms of malaria begin with their onset.
Now,
uh,
let's remember,
return to our
diagram.
The,
this process of reproduction of entering that is to say the,
um,
parasite enters the blood cell,
reproduces,
bursts the blood cell and returns to the bloodstream occurs simultaneously for
an entire brood throughout the bloodstream.
And in other words,
the,
this is happening at the same time throughout the body.
And it's when the,
there are sufficient numbers of the parasite in the open bloodstream that the
immune system of the body can detect the parasite and it's then that symptoms
begin
the,
uh,
term for malaria.
Also,
it has many names.
This disease,
it was often called intermittent fever.
This process of synchronicity was known as gold.
Geez.
Law after the malaria ologists Camilo Golgi who discovered it,
and he talked about the different timings of fever,
Turshen fever.
That is to say every,
um,
48 hours or quartan fever every 72 hours or quotidian feared fever.
You can also have a about of intense fever every 24 hours.
And that means that you have more than one species of plasmodium in your
bloodstream.
You don't have to choose just one.
You can have several species and several,
um,
uh,
types in your bloodstream at once.
If that occurs,
you can have a fever,
intermittent fever every 24 hours.
So the recurring classic symptoms.
Then ours,
this intermittent fever recurring at regular intervals,
like a train schedule,
so you have recurring power,
sexisms of high temperature plus chills for few sweating,
headache,
general malaise,
exhaustion,
and with it often nausea,
vomiting and diarrhea.
The precise symptoms depend on the species of plasmodium and the most very Olin
is plasmodium falciparum,
which causes the most frequent life threatening complications and plasmodium
malaria and DoVall lay are the most mild.
You see that by entering the red and attacking red blood cells,
the parasite initiate a cascade of consequences.
The red cells can become mush shapen and they adhere to one another in clumps,
thereby causing blockages and bud cells,
blood vessels that can be rapidly fatal depending on the organ that's affected.
A frequent cause of mortality is cerebral malaria in which there are blockages
in the brain,
but the heart can also be affected or the gastrointestinal system.
And if malaria attacks the gastrointestinal in particular,
it mimics the symptoms of Asiatic cholera,
destruction of the red blood cells also as a cause of profound anemia.
Another important symptom of the disease is um,
and this is a child who's a malaria patient and what you see as a painful and
pronounced swelling of the spleen.
Ah,
this looks one of the classic signs of malarial infection,
as I've said.
Also,
malaria is a terrible,
and it's affects on pregnant women leading to hemorrhaging and miscarriage and
also to congenital malaria with infants born with the disease.
Malaria also is a disease that's a major immunosuppress suppressive disease.
It suppresses the immune system of the body and therefore gives rights to
complications,
especially respiratory diseases,
as I mentioned earlier,
pneumonia influence on tuberculosis.
So we should say that the tuberculosis emergency in the present day and the
malaria emergency are interlocking and interrelated that malaria provides the
substratum for rampaging reemerging tuberculosis.
I also said that recurring bouts of malaria lead to neurological damage and in
the worst cases to estate known as Kikexia and which your person is
indifferent to his or her surroundings as unable to learn to be productive,
to take part and civil society.
Now another feature of malaria is that it can lead to relapses.
That is with plasmodium vivax.
You remember that after the plasmodium is injected into the bloodstream,
it migrates to the liver.
Well,
in plasmodium vivax the parasite does emerge but not all of the parasites.
They continue to Nussle in the liver and they're beyond the detection of the
immune system and they can then even after the patient thinks that he or she has
recovered,
there can be a relapse when the plasmodium parasites reemerge from the liver
into the bloodstream.
This can be months later or even years later after the initial infection.
Immunity that is,
AH,
once you've had lots of bouts of malaria and you survive,
you develop a partial immunity and acquired immunity,
but it is short term and it's also at considerable cost in terms of neurological
damage to the body.
Well,
the impact on society,
as you can imagine,
is severe and we'll be talking about that next time,
but it leads this disease.
You can the symptoms listing the symptoms helps us to understand that someone
like this as an adult who's anemic,
who has perhaps respiratory diseases,
moves painfully and slowly and is therefore not a productive worker and
agriculture or an industry.
So malaria leads to backward systems of cultivation,
low productivity and lack of investment in agriculture.
It leads to the desertion of hold of some of the most fertile areas,
land because it's particularly dangerous and known to be some.
It leads then to poverty,
to illiteracy,
and indeed malaria and poverty are mutually reinforcing and a kind of vicious
downward spiral.
Poverty makes people vulnerable to the disease.
Poverty that is,
makes people vulnerable because it causes them to live in poor housing,
overcrowded housing,
housing,
that's volume,
the porous and vulnerable to flying insects.
It also leads to them to occupational hazards and having to work in areas where
the disease is prevalent.
It leads to poor diet,
which makes people more vulnerable to inadequate clothing,
which makes them more vulnerable to biting insects.
But Malaria and turn then leads to for further poverty,
the burden of looking after the ill that falls on families and communities,
low productivity,
low wages,
limited education.
This was what Ross meant when he says those malaria doesn't kill it in slaves.
Well,
when was the mosquito theory of transmission unraveled and how so?
The idea that mosquitoes were involved in this disease wasn't at all obvious.
It wasn't obvious because well,
first of all,
scientists and physicians knew that there are lots of places where there are
gazillions of mosquitoes and no malaria.
It was also clear that mosquitoes,
there was no clear correlation between bitten being bitten by mosquitoes and
developing the disease.
And so the dominant theory in the 19th century was of Miasma TISM as the cause
of the disease,
the unraveling of the disease.
Uh,
you'll remember this man,
Patrick Manson,
the father of tropical medicine.
He was also one of the figures who is most closely associated in the development
of tropical medicine and of the mosquito theory of transmission,
which he discovered for a different disease called full area.
And then he had the idea that perhaps if malaria can be transmitted by
mosquitoes,
possibly malaria could as well and suing get joined forces he worked Manson for
in London.
This is Ronald Ross who was a British military physician working in India.
Now India was a tremendously important place in terms of malaria.
Let me just,
there was a book that you might be interested in and that I would recommend to
those of you who are,
which is the correspondence between Ronald Ross and Patrick Manson that led them
to the discovery of the mosquito theory of transmission.
Now Mount Ross worked in India and he noted that,
uh,
malaria amongst the general population of India in the 1890s led to 5 million
deaths.
Um,
and he said that it was the greatest problem of public health in India.
I think on the whole,
he wrote that of the Indian population of 400 million,
it causes directly or indirectly 10,000 deaths a day and depart from this amount
of sickness,
malaria is of all diseases,
the most important and political,
agricultural and military affairs he wrote since it renders large tracks of
fertile land,
uninhabitable impedes cultivation,
planting and public works and is the most very vicious enemy that armies in the
field have to contend against.
On the whole,
I think we're justified in claiming that the malaria question is as important as
famine or boob.
Onic Plagge
well,
in India,
what Ross and Manson did was to discover,
let's go back to
picture of the life cycle of malaria.
Um,
they traced through microscopy,
the we're able to detect in the body of the mosquito after it had bitten.
Uh,
and they did experiments in which they are among not human beings,
but birds.
And they discovered that it was possible to detect the plasmodium responsible
for avian malaria under the microscope in the body of the mosquito.
That was a first major insight that the mosquito was in some way implicated.
But then they went further and they followed the process by which the,
uh,
it changed various phases in the body of the insect and reproduce.
And they traced the f the migration of the pliers parasite to the biting
apparatus of the mosquito.
And then they were able to take healthy birds and have mosquitoes who were known
to be infected feast on them and to produce malaria experimentally on birds.
And so in 1898 if you were reading this correspondence,
there's a Eureka moment in which,
um,
Ross announces that he's discovered the mosquito theory of transmission and
proved it,
and he claims that he feels like captain cook the explorer,
or possibly like Napoleon.
Um,
and he was not,
however,
a naturalist and he didn't know,
he didn't know about the speciation of mosquitoes and the mosquitoes he
described,
he described as dappled brindles or light brown.
He didn't know about species of an awful least mosquitoes.
And it's at this point that we should mention then a second major figure.
Oops.
Uh,
anyway,
we'll see.
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
Giovanni Battista Ghidossi who was,
uh,
the next figure in the development of the mosquito theory of transmission.
And he does so for human beings.
Um,
and what he does is he discovers that it's possible,
uh,
and a place called Cappaccio.
He takes railroad workers in the midst of a major malaria epidemic in the summer
and he introduces one variable in their lives from a control group of railroad
workers and the surrounding peasant tree.
And that is that one group he has living at from dusk until dawn in well
screened houses.
And this difference,
protecting them from the one factor which is a from miss,
the bikes of mosquitoes prevents there being a contracting malaria.
This was one place in which he did that.
And then he also did the,
uh,
a different experiment,
which was to use Quinine,
which,
uh,
kills malaria parasites in the open bloodstream.
He gave it prophylactically to a series of workers as a control group in a place
like Australia during the summer malaria season,
and found that he could protect them as well from malaria by caping establishing
a chemical barrier between the mosquitoes and human beings.
And then he took the further step of actually taking mosquitoes who are known to
a feasted on people ill of malaria and took them to a hospital in Rome,
known as the Santo Spitty to hospital where he had a volunteer on the second
floor who was,
uh,
in a room where at night they released hundreds of intentionally infected
mosquitoes.
And a couple of weeks later they had their Eureka moment when,
uh,
he had a spike and a temperature of 104.
And they knew that they had successfully transmitted malaria by human
experimentation to someone who had been healthy until mosquitoes infected with
the disease had been allowed to feast upon him.
So,
uh,
this is then by happens between 1898 and 1901.
And this then is a powerful factor in the development of tropical medicine,
but it also leads to programs to combat malaria having discovered the pathogen
responsible to it,
the plasma Modia and the vector female anopheles mosquitoes.
We see the development of public health programs to destroy the disease either
by attacking the plasmodium with,
um,
chemical therapy that is through quinine or by killing mosquitoes.
That is vector control,
the idea of possibly being able to eradicate malaria.
And next time,
what I'd like to do is to follow the practical application then of the
discoveries we've talked about today,
about the lifecycle of plasmodium and have an awfully mosquitoes and see how
that leads to the development of public health strategies.
And I'd like to talk about how those strategies are being used in the real world
today to combat this crisis of this dreadful,
um,
vector born disease.